[Music]
is my vote worthless i'm considering not
voting is this a privileged position
well let's talk about privilege but
before we get into that i have i
i've blacked out my address here but i
have my ballot it's i haven't gone
through it i'm opening it here on the
podcast yeah
we'll get post-production uh p3 he can
hear this here right you can you get all
the uh the unwrapping of the ballots by
the way josh if i convinced you to vote
for the person i wanted to vote for
that's not consent
absolutely yeah and so
my wife has this t-shirt that says like
coercion is not
consent but i would say that convincing
is also not consent and so i've got my
little virtue signal here um i'll throw
this on
um
i
voted today
that look good on me jordan they haven't
changed that sticker in like five years
all right and so there's so many it's
like it's the same one so many people i
can so let me let me set this up ryan
because you and i had this conversation
on the podcast and some people got
frustrated because i simply asked the
question i said hey i'm voting this
coming weekend but i'm just wondering
like
does it even make sense to vote does my
and so like i'm glad daniel's question
came up here because it's very similar
to a question i had before and so i do
plan on voting in this election but what
i will tell you and maybe tk can even
challenge me on this is i will spend
somewhere between six and eight hours of
my time it's miserable
researching of them don't have a website
yeah and then i automatically like cross
them out if you couldn't bother to have
a website at this point yeah but like
it's so many people i have to i mean
look national election the united states
senator full term
and then there's one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
different people wait oh no keeps going
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 people
or write in candidate which so 23 people
that i have to research if i want to
vote for
any of of these people because i feel as
though
well if i don't if i vote blindly which
i've done in the past
did i waste my vote
but getting back to daniel's question so
i have to do this for every single issue
on here and it's a huge you can hear
this if you're just listening here i
mean it's a thick
ballot this page is intentionally left
blank um
says that in writing which is strange
don't we have that in our book
[Laughter]
um we stole it from the ballot yeah so i
go through any one of these and it's
going to take me six to eight hours so
yeah and so what's the charitable
response to daniel when he says is my
vote worthless i'm considering not
voting and also is this a privileged
position
um
okay
okay so a few different elements here
number one is this a privileged position
i think that's irrelevant not irrelevant
in the sense that i am going to dismiss
your question and that your concern is
important but irrelevant in the sense
that no matter how you come down on the
privilege issue it still doesn't answer
the question or get to the heart of
things case in point hey i have 10
million dollars and i'm not sure how i
want to spend it should i give it to
charity should i buy a ferrari should i
buy a mansion is this a privilege
problem guys
yes it's definitely a privileged problem
secondly it tells you nothing whatsoever
about what you need to do with that
money yeah you still have the question
there you have 10 million dollars
absolutely that's a privileged problem
that most people are never going to have
but it doesn't matter having a
privileged problem doesn't mean that
it's that that's a problem right we are
all privileged in different areas from
one another privilege in this sense just
means
you have the luxury
of possessing problems that stem from
having advantages
and we live in a world that makes us
feel as if we have to apologize for
having our advantages you don't have to
apologize for having your advantages in
fact apologizing for your advantages
just waste the valuable time you need to
be spending on what am i going to do
with these advantages how am i going to
express the advantages i have or use
them in a way that's advantageous in a
way that's healthy and so on so
if you got 10 million dollars and you
don't know how to spend it yes that's a
privilege problem but we still have the
question what do we want to do what
reflects your values so that's the first
part don't spend so much time worrying
about if your problems are privileged or
not maybe they are maybe they're not
yeah secondly um is my vote worthless
neither your vote nor your non-vote is
ever worthless because everything that
you do sends an economic signal into the
marking place if you don't vote that's
actually an action that has impact
if you do vote that's an action that has
impact and who you vote for is an action
that has impact so nothing that you do
in the realm of voting is worthless your
action always matters if you don't show
up it makes a difference if you do show
up it makes a difference it's just the
question of how does it make a
difference and now that leads us to the
real heart of the question
should i vote
that's the underlying question right
yeah should i vote and this is
interesting because there are a couple
of things built into it number one
there is some sense of like having an
obligation
right because if there was merely
disinterest in voting there would be no
question you would just act according to
that disinterest but there's kind of
like a moral hook that's got you like i
ought to do something i have a duty to
society would i be ignoring my duty to
society so there's that element that's
going on
but then there's also some
dissatisfaction with the options
there's something that makes you feel
like am i wasting my time here
and it doesn't sound like it's the sort
of thing where you feel like hey i just
hate standing in line
there seems to be a dissatisfaction with
what's being presented to you so
here's what i would say if you're at a
point in your life where you feel like i
don't even know if my vote makes a
difference i don't know if i should vote
i'm actually kind of thinking about not
voting or whatever it may be
i would say give yourself permission to
step outside of the binary logic of a
society that tells you you contribute to
evil if you don't endorse like their
two-party system that everyone worships
everyone complains about the two-party
system everyone complains about the lack
of options and then every time there's
an opportunity to vote one's conscience
people tell the same story every single
election period without an exception
they say this one is special this is the
most important one yet i've never come
across an election period that isn't the
most important one yet and that isn't
like really special like this we can't
afford this time to vote our conscience
normally if things didn't matter and
there's literally never been one of
those if things didn't matter and if
there wasn't something really big at
stake and we didn't really need to keep
this evil villain out of office then
maybe we could vote our conscience by
you know voting for a third party and
trying to contribute percentages to
another candidate being able to have a
bigger platform in an ideal world yeah
fine but we gotta vote for the lesser of
two evils and this is a game that gets
played every single time again show me
the election that didn't matter where we
could afford to vote our conscience
you got to give yourself permission to
not make decisions based on the guilt
tripping that other people are doing to
you and you've got to vote your
conscience for me that's taken the form
of not voting at all not endorsing a
system that i don't believe in not
endorsing a system that i think is
artificial that i think is manipulated
that i think is designed to pacify us by
convincing us that we're having an
impact when the real impact is elsewhere
for me that's what voting my conscience
has taken the form of i don't condemn
other people who vote their conscience
in a different direction for some people
voting their conscience has meant i'm
going to vote for someone that i believe
in even though i know the chances of
them winning are low
because i want to do what's right not do
something that i think is wrong or that
doesn't reflect my values just because i
think it's going to have a
um
more likely to be on the winning side or
something like that so i i think the
answer here is to get rid of externally
imposed shoulds and be driven by your
own internal values follow your
conscience if that means not voting if
that means voting outside the binary
logic of the two-party system give
yourself permission to do it and know
that no matter what you do there will be
self-righteous people who condemn you
for it and try to make you feel guilty
about it and there's no choice you can
make that's going to escape that fact
just own who you want to be on what you
actually believe can we talk about one
other component of this i think there is
a
opportunity cost component because if i
spend eight hours researching all of the
different candidates i'm responsible
which is also a societal construct right
voting
responsibility is a contract any sort of
responsibility and i'm not saying that
it's wrong i'm just simply saying i
understand that quite often the things
we think we're responsible for simply
mimetic responsibilities
and when i look at the opportunity cost
what else could i do with those eight
hours or if i have to wait in line for
two hours now it's 10 hours and so is
this the best use of 10 hours for me
because this is not an infinite resource
and so i'll never get that time back and
if i can answer yes i think this is the
best use of these 10 hours not because
someone bullied me into voting
but because
for me
this is the most compelling thing to do
with my 1 2 5 10 hours
then i can make that decision and feel
outstanding about it but if i decide you
know what
i'd rather spend 10 hours working in a
soup kitchen i'm not wrong for that
either or by the way 10 hours watching
you ozark i'm not wrong for that either
right
the 10 hours of watching ozark might
have a higher probability of taking you
somewhere that you don't want to be
based on your own principles and
preferences
but that's a question again of is it
healthy or not healthy does it work or
does it not work based on my own values
but you know one thing i would encourage
people if i can just go ahead and push
my agenda explicitly for a quick minute
um because this is my agenda this is
what my life is all about and if i had
to reduce the meaning of my existence to
a single thing i'm quite comfortable
being oversimplified as a guy that's
only about this and nothing else and
that
is find something you feel passionate
about
that can make a society freer starting
with yourself and the people within your
sphere of influence and dedicate
yourself to that with the very same
fervor that people have towards politics
politics is not a substitute for
self-actualization politics is not a
substitute for spirituality and although
it has a role it becomes a very
dangerous preoccupation when we use it
as a substitute for those things
my biggest concern i'm not afraid of who
anybody out there votes for there's
nobody that scares me because i think
they're gonna vote in the wrong
direction what scares me is that over
and over again this conversation about
voting and personal power is based on
the presupposition that the greatest
impact we have on society is this
decision that we make every once in a
while in the voting booth what frightens
the hell out of me is that my neighbor
doesn't take themselves seriously as a
creative force and they buy into the
illusion the self-destructive lie that
when they are not at the voting booth
what they're doing doesn't really matter
but what you do in terms of your
personal health your mental health your
creative projects your family life your
spiritual life all of those things are
things that you can vote for every
single day and if you show up 365
five days a year voting for your mental
health voting for your family voting for
your personal wellness then a lot of
these conversations about hey we're
stuck in a society where we got two
complete idiots neither of which we like
and we're forced to choose those
problems will go away because those
problems are really an extension and
expression of the fact that internally
we're so screwed up internally we don't
have any options like that's an outer
reflection of our own inner mess and if
we focus on dealing with that inner mess
a lot of these issues become a little
bit more simplified so that's my agenda
i i have no desire to play any role of
influence on how anybody out there votes
when it comes to politicians my life is
better off the less that i talk about
them but
vote for yourself please vote for your
potential both your creative power i
mean that's the biggest takeaway that
i'm hearing here it's like you do you
man
whose question is this daniels yeah
daniel you do you buddy what's gonna
make you feel good
like that's what it comes down to it
doesn't matter what i do it doesn't
matter if i sit here and i do i like i
will totally be like daniel you should
go out and vote your vote matters
because of my upbringing and i've talked
about this before in the podcast like i
was taught to not vote
to stay politically neutral because
don't worry jesus is behind the wheel
don't worry about it
um i uh as an adult i'm like oh wow i
kind of resent that so like i go out on
my way to vote i'll encourage people to
vote but me encouraging people to vote
is just like if i was to encourage
people not to vote
just push pushing my preference
drink mountain dew
isn't it funny that we also see these
campaigns of make sure you get out there
and vote every four years during the
presidential cycle we rarely talk about
that with respect to your local
mayor or yes the local sheriff which
probably has way more effect on your
life than the president does and we
definitely don't talk about it when it
comes to anything related to personal
health that would be considered imposing
your religion and root totally okay to
tell people to get out there and vote in
the name of moral duty and obligation
completely rude and insulting and
disrespectful of people's freedom to
have an opinion about their physical or
mental health hey bro i think you should
read more hey man i'm just standing out
of love man i never seen you pick up a
book you watch eight hours of tv all day
i never see you work out out of love bro
that makes me an evil villain who's so
rude who imposes a religion on people
but i can tell you to go out there and
vote and that's socially acceptable yeah
yeah and and one of those oh but that
just has to do with me you know who i
vote affects society no absolutely not
like your mental and physical health
affects everybody in your life and to a
greater degree because your voting
decisions are just an extension of that
more fundamental reality there are there
are aspects of your life that who you
vote for it don't affect there are zero
aspects of your life that your mental
health and physical health don't affect
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free